every Thursday we'll highlight important
stories affecting consumers across the
country tomorrow the FDA will hold the
first public hearing on a plan to
legalize CBD in food and drinks CBD
comes from plants in the cannabis family
but unlike marijuana it won't make you
high it's expected to be a twenty two
billion dollar industry by 2022 Barry
Peterson went to Denver to check out the
buzz over CBD infused coffee Barry what
exactly does it do well depending on the
amount people say this CBD infused
coffee helps them feel calm or focused
but you probably won't be able to taste
any difference its usual for people to
buy coffee at the Blue Sparrow but this
being Denver the blend is unusual it's
infused with CBD John McCaskill used to
drink tops of coffee daily but the CBD
version eased his coffee craving for me
it got rid of all the jitters it's not
what your drink coffee people no not the
juice no the best way I can describe it
it's kind of like taking off and then it
just levels out I had a chance to start
a coffee business but what I'm doing now
is is delivering you know a better life
to a lot of consumers
Andrew Ahmad is co-founder of Denver's
strawberry coffee this is our roastery
he started as a high-end coffee roaster
but competition forced him to be
different so he added in CBD and that's
where the misconception starts so if I
were to say to you Andrew oh you're
selling pot coffee yeah what do you say
back to them we're not selling pot
coffee we are selling a coffee that has
been infused with with nutrients from a
plant that do not have a recreational
purpose they don't produce any kind of
hi or experience like that it's
confusing pot comes from the marijuana
plant that's loaded with THC the
ingredient that creates a high but CBD
oil comes from the hemp plant soon legal
to grow across the u.s. it has trace
amounts of THC but usually too small to
make anyone high
and lately it seems like CBD is for sale
everywhere claiming to help with
everything from soreness to stress but
that depends on how your body reacts the
raw cannabis acid says Martha Montana
you're a certified nutritional
consultant so the fat part of this CBD
coffee CBD Donuts CBD spritzers is good
for you not good for you or nobody knows
some people are definitely going to feel
better
some people are going to feel nothing
back it's trauma this may be the closest
thing to coffee heaven the
quality-control tasting room Strava
founder Ahmad is my guide for my first
taste of CBD coffee tastes pretty much
like normal coffee it tastes like great
coffee caffeine is still there the CBD
is gonna balance it out just a little
bit help with maybe some some mental
clarity some focus and then help with
just kind of make things a little looser
okay so it's gonna kind of take me up
and call me down at the same time a
little bit of that strobus CBD coffee is
pricey one of the cheapest bags sells
for around $20 the most expensive with
eight times more CBD will set you back
$54.90 if that yeah it takes about 20
minutes or so and it you have to really
make sure you understand it's not pop
right I don't think I don't think our
executive producers are confidence not
pop we're going to try some of eight
o'clock to the 8:30 you an answer Tony's
question you didn't say how it made you
feel well it's supposed to make you give
you the caffeine high right and really
enjoy but it you don't get like did you
feel bad you feel that way